[Musique]
ces médecins infirmiers sages femmes et
puéricultrice sont ces agents qui
exercent des missions essentielles et
d'urgence en continu malgré
l'application des mesures de confinement
au sein de ce centre de protection
maternelle et infantile
ses agents assurent le suivi médical des
jeunes enfants ainsi que le soutien à la
parentalité
on est un service sans laisser la santé
publique et on a en plus en charge aussi
un public vulnérable donc il faut qu'on
soit là il faut qu'on soit là pour la
vaccination il n'est pas question qu'une
autre épidémie surgissent seins des
coqueluches de rougeole etc et on doit
on doit avec la présence d'un public
il ya de plus en plus on sait qu'on
s'est aperçu que le confinement année
les augmentations de conflits au sein
des familles on arrive à répondre aussi
à ces questions on a placé 9
départements 13 centres de pmi sont
actuellement ouverts sur l'ensemble du
territoire et 150 agents sont présents
pour assurer les consultations les
visites à domicile ainsi que les suivis
médicaux depuis le début du confinement
les trois pmi du secteur nord ont traité
plus de 4000 appels téléphoniques et
réalisé près de 500 consultations en a
maintenu bien sûr un footing et services
dans tous les domaines mais possible
concerne les paieries la politique
familiale à politique de la petite
enfance
on l'avait encore plus et je salue le
travail des agents de nos pme comme de
l'ensemble des agents de la collectivité
se sont mobilisés le département dans le
cadre de ses actions sociales et
d'accompagnement familial met en place
une plateforme téléphonique à
destination des professionnels de la
petite enfance
cela va permettre d'avoir des conseils
une orientation une formation avec une
puéricultrice référente au vide pmi
petite enfance très concrètement comment
organiser son quotidien
comment adopter les bons réflexes les
bons gestes barrières comme ans équipé
pour accueillir
l'enfant est également comment se
préparer à la levée du confinement ou à
une reprise d'activité
un numéro unique est mise en service le
02 62 90 33 20 il sera disponible du
lundi au vendredi de 8 heures à 13
heures
[Musique]